entre l'eau et la terre.
Sur les berges du Richelieu,
Champlain et de la frontière
américaine. Mais Noyan,
c'est aussi des champs de maïs
à perte de vue.
Sans surprise, l'épluchette
constitue donc le clou de
L'occasion pour les résidents
de Noyan de se détendr, de se
retrouver après une pandémie
de division. Dans le village,
les pancartes électorales ont
fait leur apparition.
pas ici. Tout au plus offre-t-
elle l'occasion d'accorder
une note au gouvernement
de la crise sanitaire.
SYLVIE CASTEL
- Ben, il a quand même été bien
MARIE-CHRISTINE LAFORGUE
- Moi, je suis satisfaite
de ce qui a été fait.
Puis, je trouve queememememememi
au moment où ce qu'il fallait
qu'il agisse.
MARIE-JOSÉE BERNIER-LESSARD
- Oui, je veux bien croire qu'il
protéger, mais de là à imposer
le port du masque. Moi, ça,
j'en veux pas.
MICHEL BARKER
- Je suis content de la manière
qu'ils ont fait le maximum
pour protéger le monde.
- Des opinions sans doute pas
très éloignées de ce qui se dit
ailleurs au Québec. Car Noyan
appeler un village baromètre.
Depuis trois scrutins,
les électeurs de Noyan votent
au gré du vent. Chaque fois
pour le parti appelé à former
Autre particularité locale :
les gens, i,i, ont voté pour
la Coalition avenir Québec
lors de la dernière élection.
Avant
une députée conservatrice
après le changement d'allégeance
de Claire Samson.
Chez les Ryan, on cultive
la terre de père en fils.ttttttt
la fierté de Réal.i i i i i i e
de Noyan. Et le développement
des régions est au coeur
de ses préoccupations.icicicicir
et maire de Noyan
- La ruralité fait partie
du Québec. Et regardez
sur le territoire du Québec.
Ça représente probablement 80 %
du Québec, là. Il faut en tenir
compte aussi de leurs besoins
de priorités.tététététététététéé
de trouver des travailleurstutux
obstacles au développement.
- C'est sûr que le dossier
c'est très, très préoccupant.
- - La ferme de Réal Ryan se
trouve à deux kilomètres
de la frontière américaine.
ouvrir davantage, selon lui,
pour pallier au problème
de pénurie de main-d'oeuvre.
- C'est sûr, on en a besoin.
Oui. Ça va aider à combler
d'oeuvre. Bon, c'est bon d'avoir
des gens de chez nous, mais
des gens de chez nous.
- - La fromagerie Fritz Kaiser t
probablement le plus gros
employeur du village.n n n n në.
Les 18 employés à plein temps
ne suffisent clairement pas
à la tâche. Mais, incapable
de recruter davantage,
le patron a dû se rabattre
sur l'automatisation.
Comme ce robot, programmé
pour laver les fromages.
Dans ce contexte, Fritz Kaiser
digère mal les propos
de François Legault
sur l'immigration.
FRITZ KAISER, maître fromager
Fromagerie Fritz Kaiser- Les fre
parlent pas la langue? Pour moi,
ça fait pas de sens du touididi.
- Pour ce Québécois d'origine
suisse, les immigrants sont
une richesse pour le Québec,
pas une menace. Qu o o o o o o .
- Moi, mon français, c'est
je ne suis pas parfait,
mais on apprd.d.ieieieieieieiei,
face au célèbre pont tournant,
sese dresse un géant solitaire.
Le plus gros arbre du ébébec,
selon les gens du coin, qui
en sont très fiers.
PAUL PICARD
- Ça, c'est un peuplier
deltoi
135 pieds de hauteur.
C'est 28 pieds de circonférence.
Ça prend cinq grandes personnes,
des grandes, pas des petites là,
- Une attraction touristique
situ
Picard. Mais l'homme d'affaires
n'en profite plus. Son auberge
est fermée depuis quelques
années et à vendre.
- C'est un problème de main-
de cinq à six personnes.
- L'homme ne cache pas
son insatisfaction au sujet
du gouvernement sortant.
- Pour réellement aidersosososos
de zéro.
- Mais Paul Picard se pense
- Avec ce que j'entends partout,
là, les gensonont voter CAQ
encore parce que c'est eux
autres qui risquent d'avoir le
des gens de la place. C'est
de voter pour celui qui va être
au pouvoir pour être capable
- C'est donc potentiellement
là le secret des électeurs
de Noyan. Si ce village-
de l'ensemble du Québec quant
aux intentionse e vote,
c'est peut-être tout simplement
un reflet du pragmatisme